when you were at nyu and you decided you
wanted a career in show business yes and
you figured out you wanted to be a
stand-up comic you described it as being
like you were so nervous yes and you
hated it really you hated stand-up
comedy yeah you had to do it because you
saw it as a way to sort of make your
mark i i i was addicted to it yeah i
would book myself as much as possible
but it was like i was never sure if i
was gonna i i ate it a lot i didn't do
well a lot of times so i i
and i would get angry up there and i
wouldn't make make the room
uncomfortable and stuff and so i always
i was that you didn't have material or
that your material just was too
weird it was my
i don't think i was i'm not as sharp as
some of the other guys that we grew up
with like and and i wasn't as prepared
when things went off in other words what
you didn't memorize your stuff i tried
to but i would choke i would choke i
would like i would choke memorizing my
jokes and i would panic and i would see
stars and stuff and i was gulping uh you
know like when i used to get yelled at
in school a lot i used to get that gulp
like i was a borderline gonna cry it
seems like
it seems like some guys like when you
were doing stand-up who was around like
chris rocket started it was yes you
colin quinn
david spade yeah i i was in new york
first with with uh uh i used to do pips
a lot i used to do pips with otto and
george and uh
otto and george
george he was he was great to me yeah he
was the ventriloquist with the dirty
puppet exactly yeah yeah that was a good
act yeah it was a great act
and i was 17 i was 17 at nyu and i used
to the reason i would get booked a lot
is i had a uh car i i would i would so i
would be a driver those guys bob woods
and all those guys all those guys you
were around and and some of those guys
it seemed like were naturals right they
could just go it was just a little more
ballsy i i had some balls i was but my i
was kind of dopey
and uh and i didn't realize i was on a
mission a little bit when i was like i
gotta i gotta become a
star
and that i gotta get on saturday night
live and all that was that part of it
because you said when you were little
you really were into uh mel brooks
movies and stuff like that so you
probably see yourself more as an actor
maybe and and a guy who would do his
schedule eddie murphy i kind of wanted
i love rodney and eddie murphy and
that's who i uh
i would tell people i'm going to be when
i left my hometown i was like hey i'm
going to be the next daddy yeah what do
you want to be when you grow i'm going
to either be eddie murphy or rodney
dangerfield yeah
and you sound like an [ __ ] when you
say that to people they don't believe
who says these kind of i know i hate a
lot of the things i said growing up i
found it fascinating that when you got
into nyu one of the ways you supported
yourself you would go down to the subway
yeah yeah and you would actually
panhandle you would play your guitar
yeah you would play beatles cover songs
am i correct you're good and you would
play these songs and people gave you
money i did i did fine i would get
20 bucks about an hour and a half what
did you do to get on saturday night live
like what was your end you did stand up
dennis miller saw he saw me at the
improv so you must have been good i i
had some good jokes no i wasn't no i was
i was our i could i mean i did all right
were you shocked when miller said i know
this guy adam sandler he's really funny
and he says to lauren why don't you come
audition and all i mean that's very
generous
i i love him and he he it was they were
looking for new guys and actually the
night i got on rock was on the uh
me and him auditioned in chicago that
night it was you and chris rock right
right and lauren
lorne loved uh rock
and immediately put him in the cast and
i had some interesting jokes that he
liked and he he thought maybe i could
write for the show and you were pissed
right because you want you didn't want
to be a writer you wanted to be
performing i didn't know anything about
writing and i didn't know i yeah it was
just yet another like no this guy
doesn't get it i'm the next day man
you're right
but but uh wisely miller i think said to
you
take the riding job you'll get your foot
in the door yes yeah were you gonna
actually consider turning down yes i for
a minute i was young and i just did
exactly what my father told me to do or
what my friends were saying and some of
them were like what a writer no don't do
that i was like okay i can't do it then
rockets to be on camera right you're
gonna be a writer right it was it was
slight heartache and i was flying back
and i called on the plane back back then
it was a big deal to blow 15
bucks on the uh to use the phone on the
airplane and i couldn't believe i was
actually doing it i knew my father
possibly could beat the [ __ ] out of me
for that move but
i called uh my agent yeah and i said
how'd they like me they liked you good
news they liked you they they thought
some of your jokes were good they they
actually want you to be a writer and
and i remember flying back just shook up
like that they don't get it yeah a
little bit yeah but it was smart that
you went because you got your foot in
the door yes